ces derniers jours l'actualité en france
est riche et elle n'est pas des plus
joyeuses
hier c'est la suspension du compte 2000
à sur twitter qui a fait beaucoup réagir
la jeune femme qui avait déjà été
victime de harcèlement sur les réseaux
sociaux pour ses propos sur l'islam
s'est vu fermer son compte twitter pour
le poste d'un dessin de pain au chocolat
un simple dessin d'enfant qui lui a valu
un flot d'insultés gratuites et la
suspension de son compte twitter durant
24 heures
les réseaux sociaux sont ils dangereux
l'autre information celle du mode de la
petite à licha cette collégienne
d'argenteuil retrouvé noyé dans la seine
lundi dernier à licha s'était confiée à
sa mère elle était harcelé et menacé
depuis plusieurs semaines par deux
camarades de classe la jeune fille
aurait été la victime d'un triangle
amoureux qui aurait mal tourné
mais comment peut-on en arriver à une
telle violence ce soir marlène schiappa
répond à toutes vos questions sur le
plateau de thé pmp merci d'être là
marlène schiappa vous êtes voilà vous
faites équipe et c'est vrai qu'on est
vraiment en direct comme on peut vous le
montrer et on va revenir sur beaucoup de
choses avec vous et surtout sur ces deux
faits le drama licha déjà on va parler
de ça dans un instant ce drame qui a
bouleversé toute la france ce week-end
halliche à 14 ans elle était retrouvée
morte noyée dans la seine et suspects
sont deux adolescents camarades de
classe de la victime il aurait tendu un
guet-apens
sur fond de rivalités et de dérapages
sur les réseaux sociaux va revoir
l'image de l'hommage rendu par sa maman
qui vous avez froid dans le dos c'était
hier lors d'un rassemblement en hommage
à licha regardez je n'arrive pas à
croire qu'il m'a vu
ce aux dépens protat les miaulements
n'empêche que quand il ya tant dans les
jours que ma fille mone à la maison je
me rends hommage
[Musique]
les images très dures un pense bien
entendu à toute la famille d'al hicha sa
maman notamment et on se masse à la
place de sa maman et justement marlène
schiappa la première question que j'ai
envie de vous poser c'est comment on
peut faire en sorte que ce drame c'est
drame n'arrive plus parce que c'est vrai
que ça ça nous a bouleversé sa
bouleversé tout le monde tout le
week-end les plus âgés et les plus
jeunes comment comment on peut faire
comment le gouvernement peut agir pour
ça pour que ça n'arrive
d'abord je voudrais dire que on adresse
évidemment un message de soutien à la
maman d'al-hicha son papa aussi à toute
sa famille avait ses frères et soeurs
qui est sauce mots qui se sont exprimés
les dernières heures de cette jeune
fille elles ont manifestement
probablement lé enquête devra le dire
mais probablement été d'une violence et
d'une douleur terrible
évidemment on pense à elles et on lui
rend hommage avant tout ensuite oui
effectivement moi je pense qu'il ya des
actions à mener puisque quand on regarde
ce qui se serait passé et encore une
fois sous réserve de ce que dira l
enquête mais il semble que manifestement
il ya des phénomènes de harcèlement
derrière notamment de cyber harcèlement
de révélations de photos intimes de
cette jeune adolescente donc en fait on
voit qu'il ya plusieurs phénomènes les
uns avec les autres
moi je crois que il ya un quantis pas ce
genre de phénomènes de harcèlement de
violence entre les jeunes souvent on se
dit mais que fait l'éducation nationale
que fait la police que c'est l'état moi
je crois qu'il ya des acteurs qui
doivent être mieux outillé ce sont les
parents et je pense qu'il ya des parents
qui sont parfois démunis quand notre
enfant est victime de harcèlement mais
aussi quand notre enfant prend part à
des phénomènes de harcèlement et ça je
crois que c'est un sujet assez tabou
mais il faut se le dire aussi en tant
que parent moi je dis aux parents
intéressés vous à ce qui se passe dans
le téléphone de votre enfant dans
l'ordinateur de votre enfant donc nous
nous créons un comité des parents contre
le harcèle sa force à savoir hiver je
sais que salon alors c'est un organisme
qui va fédérer à la fois des
associations comme une enfance hugo des
associations de lutte contre le
harcèlement entre les jeunes des
personnels
qualifié comme fabienne servan schreiber
des représentants d'associations comme
l'association christine kelly des mamans
les familles monoparentales l'unaf des
grandes associations de familles et des
personnalités qualifiées et des parents
et l'idée c'est qu'on puisse ensemble
travailler pour mieux outiller les
parents par exemple sur les violences
conjugales on a créé des grilles
d'évaluation du danger des roues des
violences pour mettre des mots sur les
violences là c'est important pour nous
d'avoir des supports pédagogiques pour
outiller les parents et ça on va les
diffuser dans toutes les maisons
confiance et protection des familles qui
sont des lieux que la gendarmerie
nationale est en train de créer partout
sur le territoire pour que les parents
très concrètement qu'ils sont démunis
puissent aller se rendre dans ces
endroits et parler avec leurs enfants et
essayer de mettre sur la table cette
question du harcèlement entre jeunes
alors marié hier lors de la marche en
hommage à licha est un coup de gueule
qui a fait vraiment réagir je pense que
vous l'avez vu c'est un proche de la
jeune fille décédée qui expliquait qu'il
regrettait que les ministres soient sur
twitch est pas la marche en référence à
jean castex le premier ministre qui
était sur twitch avec samuel etienne est
serré voilà ça c'est un coup de gueule
qui a fait énormément parler regarder et
aujourd'hui on sait ce qu'il veut ce qui
me choque le plus c'est qu'à aucune
perte ni du gouvernement qui s'est
déplacé je trouve ça vraiment lamentable
et honteux de voix le premier ministre
qui va passer sur twitch pour un échange
avec un salut les pièces conservées di
cule corps des personnes qui meurent
c'est inacceptable c'est vrai qu'il
n'est pas de ministre à cette marche
pour moi provenaient de palais vous à
moi personnellement je n'ai jamais aux
marches blanches parce que là quoi faire
de récupération politique d'accord je
respecte vraiment la peine des familles
et il ya énormément de fait hélas de
meurtres notamment de femmes dans
lesquels j'ai beaucoup échangé avec les
familles les proches etc
on sait quand on est ministre et que
move à cette marche blanche ça veut dire
toutes les caméras vont venir nous
interroger vous demander de nous
exprimer moi je pense que c'est le temps
du deuil et des familles si eux ils
souhaitent avoir des élus locaux dont
ils sont proches qui connaissent c'est
évidemment leur choix de les inviter
mais moi je me plante pas à une marche
blanche je suis trop de respect pour
en tant que maire pour ce que ça doit
être de vivre ce deuil terrible je pense
que la place de chacun nous notre classe
elle est dans l'action et dans la mise
en place de mesures comme ce comité des
parents contrôleur bernard montiel le
portugal
effectivement effectivement les
politiques sont rarement les
avenue lors des marches blanches en
général parce que c'est ce que j'ai noté
soit on les accuse de faire de la
récupération soient effectivement il
attire la lumière comme vous le dites
et puis souvent enfin je veux dire c'est
un moment de recueillement n'a pas envie
effectivement d'être d'assister à ça si
on n'est pas conviée gilles verdez n'est
pas d'accord je suis pas d'accord madame
très franchement et un appel là alors
vous me direz l'appel il a eu lieu
pendant la marche était trop tard pour y
aller c'est un drame qui dépasse tout ce
qu'on peut endurer c'est insoutenable
moi personnellement au delà de l'aspect
humain je trouve que c'est une faute
politique qu'aucun membre du
gouvernement ne soit là pour manifester
sa solidarité
un témoignage humain une présence j'ai
pas compris mais le témoignage humain la
présence il se manifeste pas forcément
devant les caméras moyens nombre
incalculable de famille que je reçois de
famille y compris pour des faits très
médiatique
je le dis pas je fais pas de tweet je
fais pas de photo avec les familles je
reçois les familles pour cet échange
humain et moi quand j'ai entendu en tant
que maman ce qui s'est passé pour cette
jeune fille dont le corps à corps a été
jeté à la seine après avoir été tabassé
par probablement son ex petit ami ce qui
est quand même d'une violence
insoutenable
évidemment ma fille elle a le même âge
comme toutes les mères et d'ailleurs
comme tout le monde c'est une question
d'humanité j'ai évidemment car déchirer
pour cette famille je vais pas leur
voler leur deuil et leur moment de deuil
et de recueillement je pense que la
place du gouvernement effectivement dans
la compassion
elle est aussi et surtout dans l'action
à mon humble avis alors on va on va
revenir sur le deuxième sujet pour vous
l'aborder avec vous c'est bien sûr la
ferme il a puisque son compte twitter a
été suspendu hier soir avant d'être
réactivé le réseau social active a
estimé que le compte de l'adolescente ne
respectait pas les règles contre le
harcèlement à la suite d'une publication
d'un pain au chocolat voilà et myla est
à nouveau au coeur des débats et la
suspension de son compte a fait
énormément réagir aujourd'hui on a vu
des hashtags horrible aujourd'hui toute
la journée en top tweets
regardez
une nouvelle fois mille harcèlement et
réseaux sociaux ont été associés ce
week-end l'adolescente tristement
célèbre pour la polémique suite à ses
propos sur l'islam a une nouvelle fois
été harcelée sur les réseaux mais cette
fois ci pourtant la jeune femme n'avait
rien dit qu'ils pouvaient prêter à
polémique
il avait décidé de poster une photo d'un
dessin d'un pain au chocolat qu'elle a
dessinée enfants pourtant ce dessin
était prétexte à un flot d'insultés de
menaces qui a poussé twitter à suspendre
un compte mais pas celui des harceleurs
celui de millar une réaction étonnante
de la part du réseau social qui a
réactivé le compte de la jeune femme un
peu plus tard à son retour milla a posté
un message un pied de nez à ses
détracteurs
alors me l'a suspendu des réseaux
sociaux est ce que vous comprenez ou pas
oui ou non on rappelle le 18 janvier
2020 millan jeune lycéenne publie une
vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux elle est
critique fortement l'islam et
l'insultent même avec de nombreux gros
mot très vite la vidéo se répand sur les
réseaux sociaux est un énorme buzz
certains internautes qui n'acceptent pas
que l'islam soit critiques et insultes
et réagissent très violemment la jeune
fille se fait harceler
elle est insulté et menacé de mort et
mme il a été exfiltré de son lycée puis
exclu pour raisons de sécurité de
l'établissement militaire qui l'avait
accueilli elle veut aujourd'hui chez ses
parents sous protection permanente
alors donc tout serait parti d'une
publication de millas d'un vieux dessins
qu'elle aurait fait alors qu'elles
étaient en maternelle un des cinq pains
au chocolat mais selon l'adolescente
quelques minutes plus tard en réactivant
son téléphone elle est tombée sur des
centaines de messages d'insultés et on a
également vous allez voir des et voilà
des conversations de millas avec deux
jeunes gens en voilà on n'aime payer
vous allez voir ce qui s'est dit vous
géraldine maillet ou penser qu ils ont
bien fait de suspendre son compte euh
ben oui parce qu'en fait elle et elle
est traquée et elle répond et quand elle
répond c'est aussi très dur et c'est
très insultant voire et est en fait
madame madame chapeau vous vous dites
oui bien sûr le gouvernement la police
la justice l'éducation les parents
aujourd'hui le nerf de la guerre moi
j'ai l'impression c'est les réseaux
sociaux comme twitter un stade bien sûr
passe aujourd'hui tout se passe au
départ sur les réseaux sociaux
et comment comment on peut faire et ne
pas y avoir une régulation ils police
des réseaux sociaux
parce qu'en fait non géraldine beys ça
on en a parlé
cent fois ils sont dessus moi ce que
j'en ai j'aimerais qu'on reste sur le
sujet ni l'ami la vie oui alors garder
sa vie bon alors voilà moi j'aimerais
qu'on est sur le sujet mais là est ce
qu'elle a bien fait d'être est ce qu'on
a bien fait de la suspendre
et oui les réseaux sociaux sociaux il
faut le cas l'an dépasse que sa
catastrophique mais moi je pense qu'on a
bien fait je trouve que milan en fait
c'est pas grand chose c'est quelqu'un
qui parle beaucoup qui veut faire
beaucoup de buzz qui était très
insultante envers beaucoup de gens qui
continuent à insulter des gens sur les
réseaux sociaux et en l'insultant si on
l'a vu oui mais d'abord il ya plein de
gens qui ce alors je vous montrais je
vous montrais tu sais et je rentrais la
la la la conversation
regardez donc il ya quelqu'un qui lui
parle sur sur voila voila chette et
islamophobe du mérite je viole à la hâte
en quoi donc
donc scarifié ce genre de personne qu'on
a vu notamment en une du point récemment
je vois la chose qu'on en fait un peu
trop avec elle qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
manalich a pas moi je veux dire
honnêtement ce qui me m'interpelle et
j'ai fait téléphoné à twitter ce matin
j'ai été interpelé de bon matin en
voyant qu'effectivement le conte de noël
a été suspendu ce que je déplore c'est
le manque de transparence dans l'action
de modération de twitter tout dire que à
l'heure actuelle on a pas de règles
claires qui nous disent que vous soyez
milla géraldine maillet cyril hanouna
marlène schiappa si vous êtes insultant
c'est participer à un raid numérique
votre compte sera supprimé et c'est
normal en revanche quelle que soit la
personne que vous êtes si vous êtes
victimes de ce raid numérique dont vous
protégera de ce raid numérique moi je
pose une question je les pose est ce
matin publiquement à twitter france j'ai
pas de réponse combien la de modérateur
chez twitter tout je pose la question et
wes qui sont ces modérateurs on peut les
voir
est-ce qu'ils sont en france mais sans
s'est délocalisé des allées chaudes
wilder il ya des millions de tweets
c'est très compliqué mais justement
c'est dira que si on s'en donne les
moyens moi je pense que comme dirait
spiderman un grand pouvoir implique de
grandes responsabilités chez twitter les
grands auteurs twitter a un grand
pouvoir et dont je pense qu'ils doivent
aussi avoir la responsabilité de
suspendre des décomptes
vous savez moi j'ai fait voter en 2018
une loi contre les raids numérique le
cyber harcèlement
tous les jours il ya des gens qui sont
victimes de haines de propos racistes
deux menaces de propos sexistes
on a encore on a fait une exposition qui
s'appelle et 109 marianne on a
récompensé une astrophysicienne noir
fatoumata québec est une jeune
astrophysicienne qui fait le succès de
la france partout dans le monde et bien
elle a dû déplorer des phénomènes de ré
de numérique raciste contre elle
via twitter qui n'ont pas été supprimées
par twitter donc il s'appelle avec les
centres banon alors non l anc team là en
l'occurrence me semble-t-il jeuxey de
numérique la suspendre pas au chocolat
non maintenant si comme n'importe qui
elle profère des insultes oui nous
souhaitons qu'après les sur les insultes
parce que twitter n'a pas à faire un
bilan moral de ce que vous avez posté à
faire une balance à des rumeurs mais il
ya des moqueries
gilles verdez excusez moi il y avait mon
président restons moi j'aimerais qu'on
reste d'usure est est ce qu'elle est ce
qu'on a bien fait de la suspendre ou
s'il vous plaît la régulation twitter on
en a parlé 15 fois pour l'instant c'est
pas en place et on sait que cela prendra
des mois et des mois gilles verdez moi
je pense qu'il faut suspendre ses
comptes et j'aurai votre avis là-dessus
eux parce qu'il faut la protéger
d'elle-même il a je suis désolée elle
devient une sorte de symbole à vos yeux
également je le sais de la liberté
d'expression mais elle n'a pas les
épaules pour ça elle est déjà protégée
isolé entouré de ses parents avec une
protection policière
est ce qu'il faut pas un moment la coupe
et des raisons qui pour moi sont
dangereux pour elle
moi je pense à elle ses troupes et la
madame est une vraie question
philosophique que vous posez c'est à
dire à partir du moment où on est
menacée briord est-ce qu'on est en
danger et est-ce que soi même voix
restreindre sa propre liberté
d'expression ou répond parce que des
gens vous menace de mort c'est une vraie
question moi je prétends pas avoir la
réponse à cette question générale mais
je crois que ma responsabilité en tant
que gouvernement c'est permettre à
chacun de s'exprimer je ne suis pas
modératrice de twitter même une mairie
mineurs est-ce que alors là mais là il
me semble qu'elle est majeure de taille
et je crois qu'elle a 18 ans qu'il est
effectivement il ya une responsabilité
aussi des parents c'est ce qu'on ne
visait pas pape pour mille a
particulièrement mais des parents de
façon générale nadège mais moi je trouve
incroyable ce soit la victime qui se
retrouve dans la situation où son compte
soit suspendu c'est à dire que enfin
pardonnez moi mais là qu'elle a reçus
soit les raisons c'est impressionnant
oui pardon la part des parties de moi la
haine qu'elle a reçues sur les sert un
gars mais c'est pas grave la haine
qu'elle a reçues sur les réseaux je
trouve ça incroyable que ce soit elle la
victime encore une fois on est dans
l'inversion de la focus et qu'elle de
soi et je suis désolé 1 des finales et
je comprends tout à fait ce que vous
dites mais on est tous bien sûr contrôle
ahern et le déferlement de haine qui
s'abat sur nadia à chaque fois il les
menaces de mort ça c'est sûrement elle
réussir maintenant
marlène schiappa quand vous voyez en top
tweets à 14h top tweets un numéro un
hashtag jeu violent à la wii est ce que
ça vous dérange pas elle aussi elle un
joli moi ça me dérange mais là elle
avait déjà soulevé ce nom mais alors
maintenant mais surtout fait bernard
montiel ça c'est important parce qu est
ce que ça pourrait vous répondre
honnêtement si je crois que là en tant
que membre du goût
ernement là le motif de suppression des
comptes twitter ça peut pas être est ce
que ça dérange ou pas un membre du
gouvernement voyez ce que je veux c'est
pour ça non mais c'est pas légal
exactement exactement c'est la loi ou
c'est pas la loi
c'est la règle ou c'est pas la règle et
le problème c'est que là on sait pas
quelle est la règle et quand on ne sait
pas quelle est la règle elle est à
géométrie variable ce que vous comprenez
qu'il ya des joueurs sur mila il ya des
gens qui comprend qu'on se sentent
offensés évidemment mais c'est les aléas
très violente vous comprenez qu'il ya
des gens qui sont bien sûr contre les
menaces de mort sur mila mais qui sont
extrêmement français est extrêmement
triste de voir en top tweets en france à
14h37 jeu violent à la non mais attendez
évidemment c'est aimer c'est offensant
pour tout le monde je vous dis
honnêtement il n'ya pas besoin moi je ne
suis pas musulmane et je suis évidemment
pas à l'aise et par un soutien je ne
prétends pas qu'il va courir dans les
rues en créant le viol est là c'est pas
ça le sujet le sujet c'est qu'il ya deux
questions différentes
1 la critique de la religion qui est
permise et qui est possible dans la
république française
on peut critiquer même de façon
virulente une religion mais on n'a pas
le droit d'appeler à la haine des
croyants d'appeler à la haine ou à la
discrimination des musulmans de tenir
quant à nicolas labelle à la mairie
violé la loi
malgré les coups la loi gilbert s'est
pas illégal mais mais je trouve cet
sujet moi que vous n'avez pas répondu
moi j'ai beaucoup de musulmans dans mon
entourage et il m'aura d'aujourd'hui
c'est ibrahim est pas là vous vous
rendez compte
je vais bien non mais je sais bien qu'à
la liberté d'expression mais alors après
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire pardon ne me
faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas dis -
documents non mais on va pas le jury
nobel madame vient dire à l'instant que
je ne soutenait pour le soutien de dire
que le viol alors on interdisait pas je
viola la séparent h et twitter front
ennemi non mais oui je suis la patronne
de twitter france moi ce que je peux
faire c'est des lois et des lois que
j'en ai fait et j'ai fait voter à lunel
excuse en 2018
une loi contre les raids numérique on
n'a pas le droit de se mettre à 100 à
150 et de harceler quelqu'un de lui
envoyer des messages sur tout le monde
est d'accord ce soir
seul hic est qu'il n'ya pas besoin
d'être 150 récents départs madame
chaînes numériques qui est prévu contre
millas voilà je le dis oui mais ça a été
découvert sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya des gens qui ne se sont dits
rendez vous ce soir à 20 heures et où se
met à plein et où la menace de mort et
on l'insulté et on va réussir à y
arriver comme ça vous savez très bien
que moi j'appelle un moment au calme on
appelle au calme ça c'est ce qu'il faut
faire redescendre la perche sûr on peut
pas avoir dans les top tweets des
bagarres entre sauvage ça c'est pas
possible à 3 pour saison à tours respect
de chacun et au fait que chacun y
compris twitter prenne ses
responsabilités face à ces propos
légèrement ajusté que le viol c'est un
délit mesdames si vous être un crime
c'est un crime donc je acheter un jeu
violent trop petits points à la ma femme
mon voisin mont blanc c'est inadmissible
hec contre la loi n'est pas illégal
c'est immoral
alors là il souhaite c'est extrêmement
choquant mais vous le dit c'est pas
c'est pas contre la loi mois pour moi
c'était un délit excusez moi on peut pas
faire un hashtag jeu violent trop petits
points c'est scandaleux et je ne crois
pas que l'état français pour le coup dix
mois on ne peut pas écrire des choses
pareilles c'est pas vrai le dos à la cg
violent trop petit bois si on veut sarah
palin mais ce faire deux minutes un
débat juridique il n'y a pas de
jurisprudence sur cette question là non
en fait il ya des gens qui vont plaider
en vous disant ce que vous venez de dire
un avocat pour être exactement la même
chose c'est un crime de jolis quelqu'un
c'est un appel au crime et de médecine
légale il faut le condamner
et ce sera sanctionné et des gens vous
vous dirai ce cas là est une personne
matérialiser ou des substances y alizés
qui représente quelque chose auquel cas
ça ne serait pas un appel autrement je
suis passé à 32 twitter je ne suis pas
là je prends mes responsabilités qui
sont celles de faire les lois de tenter
de les faire appliquer avec plus ou
moins de succès en fonction de bon
vouloir et la coopération des 21 étapes
et madame le ministre
si je peux me permettre vous avez fait
une loi qui est qui est très bien sur le
raid
mais pour le harcèlement y a pas besoin
de faire un raid
une personne peut harceler une seule
c'est pas dans votre loi vous vous avez
fait une loi justement contre le raid
nom du harcèlement justement il ya un
moment dans cette loi qui a été fait
alors voilà même retweeter c'est
considéré comme pas d'accord mais à
presque 10
regarde jamais il a raison des retweets
c'est considéré comme participé au raid
numérique même de retweeter d'accord
mais ce que dit benjamin il a raison
sauf que berges
malheureusement si je suis autant
revoltec toi sauf que c'est pas illégal
et immoral simplement voilà et qu'à un
moment donné il faut aussi
oui mais il faut arrêter de se cacher
des recruteurs il faut arrêter ce qu'est
cheddar twitter faut que vous vous créez
vous créez des gens n'en a pas et
appelle les filtres avec des mots
interdits ça il faut faire face et des
mois ça peut te faire après sentiment
que quoi qu'elle dise quoi qu'elles
fassent vous défendez systématiquement
mis là comme si elle avait rien fait et
que c'est devenu un symbole du
harcèlement et est mort hélas quand elle
est extrêmement dur extrêmement
virulente extrêmement insultante et
violente envers là toute une communauté
qui est la communauté musulmane
je trouve ça un peu de bizarre de dire
qu'elle n'a rien fait que c'est une
victime alors ça va pardon mais voit où
vous n'étiez pas là ya 5 minutes vous
êtes le curry à autre chose mais je vous
ai dit non non c'est ça défend
systématiquement parce que c'est un
symbole du harcèlement et plusieurs
choses hein j'ai dit que moi j'étais
choqué par le fait de dire que le viol à
lacets videmment pas opportun c'est
évidemment choquant c'est damman très
choquant tout ce qu'on veut 2 ben ouais
je suis désolé mais ça peut pas être une
gamine que quand ça nous arrange mais là
et là c'est aussi une jeune fille elle a
commencé à être harcelé 14 ans 15 ans
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure moi en
tant que mère je me dis une jeune chic
et harcelé je suis désolé ouais j'ai
envie de la protéger
parce que je considère que quand
quelqu'un est offensant se comporte mal
un jury et ses bas un moment peut-être
il ya une discussion peut-être ya de
l'éducation peut être qu'à de
l'affection peut-être qu'il ya un
dialogue à mener c'est la même chose
quand on dit à des jeunes délinquants
qui ont bus 13 ans qui vont tagué qui
vont et c'est à un moment la question de
l'éducation et de la main tendue vers
l'autre elle est importante aussi est
ensuite oui bien sûr mais là c'est
devenu un symbole vous avez tout à fait
raison
pourquoi parce qu'elle est menacée de
mort principalement par des islamistes
radicaux il ya des groupes et des
sphères de gens qui sont des gens qui
font de l'apologie du terrorisme qui
appellent à sa mort vous rendez compte
de la violent mais elle aussi est
aujourd'hui tous les sens mais c'est fou
le nombre de morts on souhaite me
suicide on cherchait des photomontages
avec du sang évidemment on peut que
soutenir une adolescente qui est en
proie à saint ouen alors oui à 67 pour
son nom à 33% voile et oui les 67 % des
gens pour ce qu'il fallait
suspendre milla des réseaux sociaux